-Our next guests
are the talented members
of the Grammy-nominated band
Haim.
Their latest album,
"Women in Music Pt. III"
is out now.
Please welcome to the show Este,
Danielle, and Alana Haim.
Hello!
How are you?
-Hi.
-Long time no see.
-I know.
I feel like I've bumped into you
guys a few times over the years.
Always a delight.
The first time we met
was when you guys did "SNL
the first time in 2013.
-And you saved our lives.
-Yeah.
-I don't know
if I saved your lives.
What I remember is...
-You did.
-...I got you some alcohol
-You did,
which is saving our lives.
-[ Laughs ]
-I don't --
I feel like we were radiatin
very nervous energy, obviously
Playing "SNL" is the best
feeling in the world
but also very terrifying.
And I think,
after our first song,
you could kind of feel
our nervous energy,
and you were just like,
"You need this."
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
My memory is like --
I would like to say
that I remember that you guy
were like,
"Do you have any alcohol?"
as opposed to me, like,
showing up in the band's roo
being like,
"You ladies need a drink?"
[ Laughter ]
I was talking with our frien
in common Andy Samberg today
about how great this album is.
-Oh!
-Aww.
-And this is --
This is actually a photograph.
The cover of the album,
taken in Canter's Deli,
which is -- has a part
of your history, Canter's.
-Yeah.
-We -- We had a band
with our mom and dad
for like 15 years before
we were ever just Haim.
So we kicked our parents out o
the band and then started Haim
Before that, we were calle
Rockinhaim -- no G.
And our first --
our first gig
was at The Kibitz Room,
which is, like, the club
that's attached to Canter's.
It's really --
It's actually just a bar
with, like, a stage that's the
size of, like, my coffee table
And we --
we ended up playing there.
And, you know, I think we did --
we just played covers.
-I don't think that Canter's
knew that we were a family band.
I think I was 5 or 6
when we did it.
-Yeah, 'cause I was 11.
So mom and dad
definitely didn't disclose
like, "My kids are coming.
-That's fantastic.
-"My kids will be in the band.
And so -- and -- and yeah.
So, we played.
We had one heckler
that didn't believe
that we were actually playin
and that it was a playback
-[ Laughs ]
And what were --
And then, you know,
you guys are --
Obviously, you're from L.A
And there are venues there
and you have friends
who are in bands.
But what were the sort of band
you guys were opening for
in your early days?
-We opened up for every single
band that would let us play.
We didn't care what band it was.
If they gave us, like --
Even if it was 10 minutes,
we would play.
But I think the best show
that we played,
we played at the Troubadour,
and we opened up
for a "Harry Potter" band.
-[ Laughs ]
-And they were headlining.
And we were first of three
So we played at 7:00.
-What is a "Harry Potter" band
Are the songs -- Did they dres
like "Harry Potter"?
-Yep.
-Yeah.
-"Harry Potter"-themed songs
-Oh, wow.
-And the crowd was also showin
up in "Harry Potter" costumes.
And I don't think
that they liked us at all.
We were --
-There were --
There were a lot of
sexy Hermione costumes
in the audience.
[ Laughter ]
-It wasn't just one
"Harry Potter" band, though.
It was, like,
multiple "Harry" --
Like, after we did --
After we opened for
the Remus Lupins, it was lik
Harry and the Potters called
and was like...
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe they thought that Hai
stands for like a spell.
-Right.
-Maybe that's
how we got in the circuit.
They were like,
"Oh! A Haim spell.
We should get Haim
to open up for us.
They love "Harry Potter,"
obviously.
-2009 was a crazy time
in Haim world.
-Yeah.
People, there's gonna be
a documentary about
how the whole Sunset Strip
was "Harry Potter" bands
back in 2009.
-It kind of was.
-Guys, I'm very --
First of all, it's really luck
to have bands
who do this incredible wor
of putting together --
Obviously, if you were here,
you'd do the song right here
You have this incredible son
we're going to show.
And you've got
an incredible cameo.
I don't know --
I mean, I guess we should sa
who the cameo is
so you can talk about
how you got them
to agree to be into it.
So, you guys --
you guys drop the big news
-Well, the song
that we're doing is "3 AM.
And on record, it starts wit
kind of a voicemail,
if you will, of someone calling,
you know, at 3:00 a.m.
And basically, you know,
it's a booty call, right?
-Sure.
-So we needed --
We needed someone to do
this cameo that had game.
-Absolutely.
-And even when we were recording
the record, we held auditions,
so we thought
this would be no different
So, a couple of the names --
you know, Tom Hardy.
-Very good.
-We didn't hear back.
-Didn't hear back.
[ Laughter ]
-He's a mumbler.
He's a mumbler.
You're fine.
-Yeah.
Benedict Cumberbatch.
-Very good.
-Didn't hear back.
-No. No.
-Again, like --
Oh, and I should also say,
we wanted it to be someone
British because we wanted it
to be similar to the way
that it was on record.
-Sure, and you didn't
want to hurt my feelings,
because you never called.
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, that was --
We were saying that.
We were like, "Should we jus
have gotten Seth to do this?
-So, all right,
give them the big news.
'Cause I feel like
you hit a home run.
-So, in the end,
the person that won the part
was Robert Pattinson.
-I mean, congratulations,
you guys.
-He has so much game.
-Congratulations
to Robert Pattinson really
-Yeah, that's true.
[ Laughs ]
But Robert Pattinson --
and let me just say this -
one of my favorite guests
on this show.
Someone that I -- you know
early in his career,
I maybe underestimated
as thinking he was,
you know, sexy vampire,
makes as cool a choices
as any actor working today
and this...
-Oh, he's the best.
-...is maybe the coolest one
he's ever made.
-He's the best.
He's, like --
We -- We love him.
He really did us a solid
by doing this.
-And we hope everyone likes it
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, you guys,
I feel like we should get to i
so the world can see it.
And it has just been so lovely
to talk to you guys.
Thank you for doing a song
as well.
"Women in Music Pt. III"
is so good.
It's available now.